very excited TQ is always a good time
makes me feel special when I shoot me
thank you
Bonjour GQ my name is Kay Java and these
are my essentials like the little
Bonjour I added in there guys
[Music]
this here is a guitar made by fender I
get a closer look on that dick guitar
here I keep on set all the time I like
to color because yellow is my favorite
color any guitar is OK
I kind of live without a guitar I don't
think been playing since I was 11 years
old I'm 22 years old right now
I have many guitars but this guitar is
my favorite guitar I will not be playing
the guitar for you right now the next
essential item that we have here is
moisturizer for the face I start the day
with moisturizer I end the day with
moisturizer I have moisturizer after
lunch I have my moisturizer after
morning tea after everything really it's
really important to stay moisturize to
stay healthy and stay young I just think
it's simple you know as a man I think
typically men don't wear makeup
typically but we can do whatever we want
I don't wear makeup myself but I like to
keep it simple I think moisturizer is
the best way to do that to look after
the skin the next essential that we have
is pin any kind of pin will do the
reason why I chose a pin - instead of
like a phone or something you could
write down ones because I can live
without my phone you have problems if
you can't live without your cell phone
but a pen is a great way to drop some
notes down for me you know I like
writing letters to my girlfriend so this
is perfect for me you know what I mean
I'm writing I'm writing ideas and
constantly drawing things I'm an artist
I'm just doing on ok ok ok pin pins good
right here
but every BEC that I have backpack that
I have and 99% of the time has a pain
inside of it I'm an existential that we
have as a protein bar this part team ba
has about 200 calories in it which is a
perfect little snack I like to work out
a lot and I like to keep my diet
regularly pretty clean this is killing
you isn't it sound that's fine you can
handle it
this is just the standard kind of
chocolate chip protein bar from primer
so you can put them in the fridge harden
it up a little bit makes it last longer
cookie dough it can be really hard you
know when you're on set and you need a
quick little snack run by Crotty what
can I get a protein bar grab one of
these all sorted also really good for
traveling if you need to take a little
snack for the plane or something while
you're waiting in there and the business
lounge you can take one of these next
the next essential is a blindfold it's a
classic it's normal blindfold like so
completely blacks out everything when
you're sleeping which is really really
important if you don't have blackout
curtains which by the way is a really
good investment as well which I would
also add into the ten essentials but I
couldn't bring my blackout curtains so I
brought this blindfold really awesome
for traveling me myself because I do
travel first-class it comes with one of
these so unnecessary piece of
information there but it's all good
to my other fellow actors or other
nomads who are out there traveling all
the time you guys know you know what I'm
talking about with one of these sleep is
a necessity it's also very scarce and
the business that were in so we need to
make sure that we're looking after
ourselves and we're resting and we're
getting lots of sleep this thing it's
gonna help you with that the next
essential is headphones this is probably
one of my favorites actually out of all
the essentials
just because music I love listening to
music you can listen to music anywhere I
constantly find myself using this
essential probably more than most of the
other essential
other than the moisturizer that's it
this is a hat I have read here sometimes
you know when I go out in public it's
good to cover up the carrot top just so
I can keep it a little okay if you know
what I'm talking about the specific cat
is one of my favorite heads to but any
head will do it from outside I love this
hat it's green it's just a hat obey
worldwide but any hat like I said any
hair work as long as it covers the red
okay the next essential that we have is
a watermelon it happens to be my
favorite food I used to take watermelons
to school every day with me in my
backpack and that was my lunch I used to
cut it open and just eat it straight
straight from the thing with a spoon oh
it's been my favorite since I was a
young man but it has good on that too if
you want some hair on your watermelon
it's always nice cheers for that
it's my--here it was red but yeah what a
mile it's a great little snack it's
refreshing it's 90% water I think and
yeah that's why it's on my ten
essentials thank you it's quite heavy
yet okay now those snakes essential is
also you know up there in my favorites
Charles Melton ladies and gentleman
probably my best mate I keep this next
to my beard actually every night you
know just to remind me of you know my
friends and just look at these just as
legend getting a good close-up on that
get a good close-up if you can
that's good Charles Melton everyone
ladies and gentlemen round of applause
[Applause]
he would not be happy with that actually
there should be a lot more people
clapping okay the next essential is an
essential and I'm sure a lot of you guys
can relate to me on this one this is
coffee I can't show you that but I
promise you this coffee in here I like
my coffee black no cream no sugar it's
just a standard thing you know that I
need in my life actually just to keep me
going when times get rough on set you
know it's also another thing that if you
get hungry sometimes just have a coffee
and can just really push down the hunger
and if you need a little pick up coffees
perfect for it 15 how many cups of
coffee do I have a day closing on about
seven bean is a charge of my hair and he
makes really good coffee anyway guys
that is it for the ten essentials I
really hope that you enjoy it I wish
that I could sit here and tell you about
all my essentials all day long I have
many many more unfortunately that is at
for us GQ thank you so much for having
me have a great one guys Bob we are
[Music]